هذا المشاهدين اضراب هو الاكبر في تاريخ
نظام الصحه الحكومي في بريطانيا يستمر
لمده يومين والمطالب واحده تحسين ظروف
العمل وطبعا رفع الاجور ودعم القطع
الاضراب ادى الى الغذاء واعاده جدوله
العديد من مواعيد المرضى والعمليات
لنحو 70,000 شخص بحسب وزيره الصحه
الجاردن اكدت ان هذا الاضراب ادى لمخاوف
كبيره في حكومه ريشه سوناتا وذلك في اشاره
الى ان الممرضين في بريطانيا يضربون اليوم
للمره الاولى بعد ان خبطت فعليا الاجور
على مدى العقد المنصرم بنسبه 20% من جهتها
صحيفه دي لما قالت ان الرئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك يخطط لفرد قوانين
صارمه لمكافحه
الاضرابات وطبعا لحمايه الارواح وسبل
العايش خصوصا ان اضراب الموردين خلف قلقا
حقيقيا بالنسبه للمسؤولين الصحيين والذي
سيؤثر بالدرجه الاولى على رعايه مرضى
السرطان وكبار السن من لديهم امراض مزمنه
في حين اكدت صحيفه تايمز بان العاملين في
قطاع السياح الصحه فيتحضرون
لاضرابات هي الاطول في تاريخ بريطانيا في
حاله لم تقم حكومه سوناك بتلبيه مطالبهم
على ماذا تتركز هذه المطالب على زياده
الاجور في مواجهه تضخم تخطى احد 10%
مدفوعه بالارتفاع الحاده في اسعار الطاقه
ولا سيما بعد الغزل الروسي لاوكرانيا